Jared Goff is back here on the
Richardson show how are you Jared I'm
good I'm doing fine I think the last
time we talked was draft day you were
running around town and Chicago right
doing product yeah you're plugging
products you plug in products and no do
you still use any of those products you
do really are you just saying that
course no of course I have to you
contractually obligated to use these
products no I'm not not anymore but no
now hey look now it's just now you're
just in one game at a time mode right
here is quarterback what was it
walk me through your first chat with uh
with McVeigh what was that like when was
that dad I was in the hiring process you
know the the front office here was kind
enough to involve me in a little bit of
it and had me come down to where they
were meeting with him at and sat down
with him for about 30 minutes and
chatted about football and went on I was
really good meeting yeah he told me
about that meeting when he came in here
in June he said that he looked at every
single snap of yours that Carl did you
know and he went over those with him at
that time
no no at that time no we went over those
you know at a different time but at that
time you know he was just talking poop
always gonna know each other really
pretty clean we didn't know using your
heart right I know you can get hired
we're just getting to know each other a
little bit and I walked away from the
meeting extremely impressed though okay
and so did you have that conversation
with anybody else during the hiring
process
no no just him so maybe they really
thought this is a guy and we need to
have yeah pretty much exactly I think
that's what it was they had a pretty
good feeling about it right and so how
do you think he is affected your ability
to make plays in this league jerk
I think it's been awesome I think you
know get a chance to work with him all
the way through you know all going back
all the way to you know February March
April when we started you know I was
just getting chance to work with him and
coach the floor and coach Olson and
everyone is brought in it's been awesome
such a good experience so far right and
so what has he give me the play that you
told him I want this one cuz he said
he's putting plays in for everybody
which one is I say that you know this
one it suits me well let's keep this one
in or let's come up with this one which
ones that pledge yard I think one that
scores I like nice
any other touchdown plays you know those
are my favorites come on now Jared come
on we got a big game this week I can
give you I'm not no no I'm just saying
back in the day see this has nothing to
do with now what's the one day where
you're like you know what let's keep
this one or I like this one which is
that one oh man there's so many Irish I
really don't know I don't I don't have
it when I can put my finger up mm-hmm
you're taking a pass pass on that one
but I'm taking your next questioning me
is what you're doing right now it's okay
now in the past couple weeks there was a
report that that he's in your your your
headset for so long up until the last
second giving you audibles and and the
the conversation based off of that I'm
sure you've heard it Jared is that these
are decisions that you wouldn't be able
to make on your own if he didn't put it
in your brain what do you say about all
that it's sort of you know what goes on
when your success you start having you
know people out there you know saying
some outrageous things we just like
anyone else only the headset goes up to
15 seconds so talk up to 15 seconds
sometimes I'll talk about two you know
25 seconds he'll talk up to 30 seconds
it changes every play and I don't think
it's any different than any other team
in the league I think when that sound
effects came out you know there were
some things that you get here in the
headset I'm just calling the play it
wasn't you know calling an audible
necessarily was just calling the play
and a lot of people have made some
assumptions from that which is fine it's
again it comes with part of being
successful and having a good year so far
so you know it's all part of it Jared
golf here in the Rich Eisen show okay
now once comes into the building Jared
is there anything particularly special
about this because of the fact that you
were drafted one two
uh yeah I'll be fun over there first
time playing each other we did you know
train together and Catchings know each
other pretty well we have the same agent
you know good friends so it'll be fun
let's get chance to play against them
but really I think you know I'll sure
he'll say the same thing we're focused
on each other's defenses honestly you
know I'm sure he'll come out prepared
and I'll try to do my best do the same
thing but you know I'm focused on you
know therapy and you know Michael
Kendricks and pleasure Cox and all those
guys yeah those are big dudes man and we
saw my where'd you watch the game last
night because those are your next two
opponents yeah we were on a plane
actually coming home from Arizona watch
it on the plane
oh yeah okay so DirecTV on the plane
it's pretty high-tech stuff ain't
interesting yeah so so so you're on air
Kroenke and you're watching this thing
did you stay for the entire game or did
you get I mean because we actually you
know lined up pretty perfectly I think
we got on a plane about when the second
quarter started okay
it ended before we got off what did you
see man a lot I have to watch the film
to get you get really good answer but
you say a lot you can see you know how
how good Seattle is and how good Philly
has really been both are really good
teams and it was competitive you know
all the way until them again and Jared
Goff joining me here on the Rich Eisen
show what part of LA life have you been
able to enjoy what do you got for me man
the weather the weather I think you know
we're so blessed here to live in
California on Los Angeles we come it's
December now it's you know 60 degrees
out and nothing better than that
okay just that's it I mean because
you're from California I mean it's not
like yeah area it's a little chillier up
there but down here you know it's so far
it hasn't been cold and I'm not gonna
lie that's been pretty lucky it's been
pretty normal all winter but you know I
do like you know going out and
everyone's well all season can get down
to LA and seeing some friends okay
can I be one of those friends here at
the show Jarrod we get the course of
course now you're just saying that you
want I know you said that to me draft
you now have a year and a half under
your belt I haven't seen you so no I
don't apologise I mean you just I just
want to make sure you have to take that
up with our people I don't control my
media schedule anymore although hold
a minute maybe maybe maybe during the
answer my headset shut off after 20
seconds and I didn't hear what you said
mate what do you think
perfect do you think that's I don't
think that's the answer huh hmm I'm not
sure that soy scooper cup still living
in your house
no he doesn't know he sees all his own
matters as well I saw that on Voyager so
he's with our agency as well I'm and he
got drafted and you know whatever was it
late April and instead of going all the
way back to Washington for the next two
weeks because I when I get drafted they
can't come straight to the team there's
like a two-week buffer before working
mini camp right so I said I had known
him prior to the draft and said humanity
need somewhere to stay you know I've got
bedrooms in the house you can stay with
man for two weeks you can see all the
way back up to Washington he was in LA
during the draft which is why I was
saying you know you stay here and so he
stayed in my house like two weeks you
know moved on with his life did you did
you charge him rent I mean what smell no
rail Rattray run free rent free did he
at least get the groceries I mean yeah
yeah his wife we cook every once which
was nice
it was actually nice to have some
company so okay so right now it's just
you bachelor showing you the place
that's uh just me and when my buddies
just we're doing me who's that can we
give a shout out high school got my
school so dude from high school is just
living in your spot right yep yep rent
free right now yeah this is a
give-and-take I get a little bit of
enjoyment to come home to nobody you
come home to at least I want to talk to
you go yeah cuz I saw that piece that
you were kind enough to do for game day
morning where was you and Cooper Cup in
your place and Michael's silver walking
around you know silver creeps me out I
know you guys are yes I couldn't get him
out
all right Jared I look forward to
watching you perform against whence and
that offense you know what they put up
obviously point for point but against
that defense and don't be a stranger
down the stretch okay I'm gonna I'm
gonna call I'm gonna call for you again
alright appreciate it you got to take
care of yourself that's Jared Goff it's
at Jared Goff sixteen the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience